while plenty of your favorite movies
actually get the critical acclaim and
box-office success they deserve there
are some amazing films that just don't
seem to click with an audience still
just because a film wasn't a box-office
success at first release doesn't mean
that it's not worth your time here are
some genuinely great movies from this
decade that bombed at the box office
free fire British director Ben Wheatley
who made the modern horror masterpiece
kill list
quietly dropped free fire in 2017 hardly
anybody saw it but free fire has got all
the makings of a cult classic the film
is a lean romp that takes place almost
entirely inside a single warehouse free
fire tells the story of an arms deal
gone wrong leaving all the lowlifes
involved trapped with nothing but their
wits and a whole lot of guns to get them
out it's filled with offbeat humor
one-liners and physical comedy that
nicely breaks the tension here and there
hey Burt does everybody like you where
you come from Fitri de mysteriis chul
Tomorrowland a fun exuberant and
inventive science fiction tale
Tomorrowland was one of the better
science fiction films of the last ten
years the film features George Clooney
as a reclusive genius inventor who meets
a science crazed teenage girl their
adventures center around Tomorrowland an
alternate dimension of scientific wonder
full of twists turns and some compelling
sci-fi concepts under director Brad
Birds expert direction
Tomorrowland deserved to be a huge hit
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world there are
movies that fail at the box office that
are only guilty of being released a few
years too early and it was clear from
the first trailer that Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world was ahead of its time director
Edgar Wright chose to ramp up the comic
book and video game influence on the
story all the way to 11 bad guys explode
in piles of coins and sound effects
appear written out on the screen
it's a self-aware and self referential
film winking at the audience constantly
and packed to the gills with nostalgia
for classic video games if released in
today's age of metatextual pop culture
the film probably would have been a
massive success hi big fan why wouldn't
you be pop star never stopped never
stopping a fake documentary spoofing
concert biopics of modern pop sensations
should be a one-note journey with a few
good jabs about Instagram culture and
auto-tune at best
instead pop star never stopped never
stopping turned into one of the best
mainstream comedies of 2016 created by
comedy music group The Lonely Island the
film stars Andy Samberg as Connor a
Justin Bieber ask pop star on the rise
it's got plenty of laughs but what's
more surprising is how much heart is
hidden beneath its many celebrity cameos
unfortunately it underperformed at the
box office but we think time is going to
be kind to this one Dredd lean
relentless and running at a breakneck
pace Dredd is a viscerally satisfying
sci-fi action film adapted from the
long-running British comic series Judge
Dredd the film sees future super cop
Judge Dredd and his trainee judge
Anderson trapped in a massive skyscraper
with hundreds of armed thugs out to kill
him leading the gang of criminals is
mama a notorious drug dealer played with
ruthless relish by Game of Thrones Lena
Headey the film is a violent brutal romp
taking Dredd and Anderson up through the
buildings many floors in increasingly
inventive action sequences
Pannalal premium rush an action crime
story set in the world of fixed-gear
bike messengers shouldn't work and yet
somehow premium rush is fantastic
premium rush is anchored by the
excellent Michael Shannon who really
shines in his role as a crooked cop as
he relentlessly pursues Joseph
gordon-levitt's bike messenger character
throughout New York City the film
showcases some killer chase sequences
and well edited action scenes the film's
nonlinear narrative seals the deal
making premium rush a whole lot of fun
and very much worth your time warrior
the story of two brothers separated as
teenagers who find themselves forced to
fight one another in a mixed martial
arts tournament sounds cliche at first
glance but warrior is surprisingly
powerful the brothers played by Joel
Edgerton and Tom Hardy have gone down
separate paths since their separation
but are perpetually tied together by
their alcoholic screw-up father warrior
is very much rocky for the UFC
generation and the movie packs the same
emotional punch of Sylvester Stallone
seminal classic this is one you
shouldn't miss but make sure you bring
tissues you'll need them you're not the
only one who suffered Tommy's
I didn't even know she was Shaykh
[Music]